applications of the sensitivity
conjecture
thanks yeah it's really wonderful
to hear um how to speak about this this
beautiful result
and uh i was just struck struck
when i saw it uh first and it's such an
elegant and beautiful
proof from the book uh for such a
long-standing conjecture
uh the sensitivity conjecture was like
to say one of the big open problems in
fascist analysis for for many years
and uh you know yeah and others have
beautiful surveys showing like a lot of
equivalent formulation of this
conjecture
so we knew that this implies a lot of
things but i guess what one of the
things that i'm going to talk about
today
are things that we didn't know that are
implied by the sensitivity conjecture
and it you really need to look into the
proof
and this notion of the islamdal f
in order to get this new result uh so
they
our application of the results in a
white box fashion i would say
so this is joint work with scott aronson
uh shall have been david and robin
qatari
and i will talk about uh the decision
free model
and the quantum version of it
and the main result is that uh the
decision tree complexity
domestic decision complexity is the most
quadratic
sorry aquatic in the quantum query
complexity
um and this is optimal and i will
mention it
later when we get to the result and this
improves the best
relation between deterministic and
quantum query complexity
the best power before our work was a
sixth power now it's
four power and the four is the right
answer
okay so i'm not assuming that you are
familiar with this notion so let's let's
introduce all these notions
so we're talking about the black box
model
uh so so we think of our input x is a
very very long stream sort of similar to
what we think
in sublinear algorithms for property
testing and this string
x is sitting inside a black box
so it's a string of length n and at
every
time step we're allowed to query this
black box at the coordinate i
and then we get an answer back exa from
the black box
okay so we can answer it ask you know
what's the seventh
seventh coordinate we get an answer back
then based on the
the outcome we may decide to query
another
coordinate maybe three and third
coordinate
and so on so forth and we usually would
want to
to answer some questions about the
string x sitting inside the black box
they satisfy some property or not
the sum function f on it equals one or
minus one
and we want to do it by making as few
queries possibly adaptive
to the black box as few as possible
okay so this is
what's called the query complexity of
the function so let's say that we have a
boolean function f mapping
strings of n bits to one bit
we said the query complexity of f is the
minimum number of queries we need to
make to this black box
in order to know the value of f on the
input x okay and we want and we want
it to take an upper bound that sort of
would work for all possible inputs
okay another way to describe this model
is a decision-free model
where decision tree is simply this uh
binary tree that you see on the right at
every time step you are querying
one variable let's say in the beginning
the root you're occurring
sorry in the root you're querying x1
right and then you know if it's if the
value of x1 is one you go
right if it's minus one you go left and
you continue
uh traversing this this tree you go
you go down a path until you reach a
leaf
and the leaf has an answer you know
either the answer is positive or
negative
and that is what you output so this is a
model of computation that
definitely describes a boolean function
so if you follow this decision tree
model this gives you a boolean function
and for every boolean function you can
build
a decision tree that computes it maybe
the depth would be
n maybe you need to query all the
coordinates but in in some cases you can
query less than on the
like the depth is is less than n and
this really corresponds to the
query complexity if you think about it
by describing how you act depending on
the the past
answers you can write down
the term for any deterministic algorithm
that has query complexity d
you can write down a decision tree with
depth at most t
and vice versa so these are just two
different ways of looking at the same
model and
right we denote by d of f for a given
function f
may have many decision trees computing
it we we denote by df of
the the depth of the best decision
pre-computing there
right or in other words the query
complexity
of f so
in in the second part of today's talk
we're going to talk about these
uh this notion of query complexity we're
going to talk about the deterministic
version of it which we already saw and
then we're going to talk about
uh the randomize and the quantum
analysis of it
okay so maybe let's start with like a
few examples just to make sure that
we're on the same page
so what is the
right so what is the decision-free
complexity of the parity function
okay so i already wrote the answers
unfortunately but uh
but but think about it let's say we want
to know if the parity of a given string
of
length n is it even or odd
so we must query all the bits if we
query
all but one bit then the last bit could
change the value of the function
right so this means that we the depth of
a decision recomputing the party
function should be at least
n and we can always have we can always
figure out the answer if we query all
the coordinates
okay so
so maybe a slightly um more interesting
problem is the or function so the or
function we want to say
either like is the string all
let's say minus ones or there exists a
coordinate for which
this coordinate equals one okay
uh so for this we also need to query all
the coordinates and and the reason is as
follows
so no matter how we gonna adaptively
choose which coordinates to read if on
the first n minus one
queries we got minus one
we still don't know the answer it could
be still the last bit that we haven't
read
is one and then the answer will be one
or it could be minus one and then the
answer would be minus one
so still for the or function we still
need to read the entire input
okay okay so so far it seems that all
the examples that we have we need to
read the encourage to figure out the
value of the function
but there are functions where uh
we need to read only login many bits and
there are functions that depends on all
the input bits
so for example let's look at the
following address function
so the address function gets
[Applause]
k plus 2 decay input bits
so let's call the first k x1 up to xk
and let's call the last one
y1 up to y2 to decay
so the first k bits define a number
between
1 and 2 to the k right we can think of
it as a binary presentation of a number
between 1 and 2 to the k
and then look at the
corresponding y j
where j corresponds to the number
described by x
okay so so this number points to one of
the bits in y
and then we output this bit in one
okay so this is called the index
function or the address function uh
we can think of like the first k bits as
the index or the pointer
and the last two the k bits as like an
array
and based on the pointer we are
selecting one entry in this array and we
output this
this speed so if you think about it
how would you implement it as a decision
tree you would query
x1
up to k and once you query all of them
you just need to query one of the y i's
so here maybe you will query i know y
one
and here where y two to the k
and then based on the answer of this y i
you would decide whether to accept or
reject
so this three would be of depth
k plus one but it really depends on all
the coordinates so really
every coordinates could make a
difference in one
first for some inputs okay
so maybe the last example is is is the
nicest one i
want to play a game let's play a game
with
prasad okay so uh
so i want to understand the
deterministic very complexity of the
majority of three bits
okay so we have x1 x2 x3 and
you want to figure out you know i have a
string in mind and you want to figure
out
you know whether the majority is one or
minus one so you are allowed to ask me
questions so
feel free to ask me questions
that's what yeah sorry what is the first
bit
yeah it's one what is the second bit
it's minus one i still don't know what's
the third bit
okay yeah it's it's one okay so yeah so
so you you see that
uh you know by answering uh
an adversary could answer question in a
way that that the decision would still
not be
known right so so prasad i'm sort of
going to keep
balancing the ones and minus one in my
answers until
possible we need to ask all the
questions in the end
so and and this adversity method is
actually uh
a way to to show lower bounds on this
deterministic
decision-free complexity and there's
also a quantum analog of it which we'll
get
to later okay
so i just want to say that all the
things that you we heard so far in
um in house talk are
sort of motivated uh we're motivated
initially and are still motivated by
by the decision tree complexity and for
example block sensitivity
is a complexity measure that was
invented to lower bond
uh the deterministic decision
pre-complexity
okay so let's talk about like
some other um
variants of this model so we talked
about deterministic algorithms
we can also talk about randomized
algorithm
um or randomized algorithms that makes
few queries
so this corresponds to a randomized
decision tree
you can write it in two different ways
so on the left
you see that you have you know every
node either queries a variable
or flips a coin okay
um and by the depth i'm querying i'm
looking at the the longest path and i'm
counting only
queries along this path i'm not counting
coin flips
okay but but this is equivalent to just
making all the
random choices in advance so you can
sort of flip all the points in advance
and then make all the the rest of the
decisions
deterministically after flipping these
coins so basically you can you can pull
the randomness
to the top of the tree and think of it
as as follows
you have some probability distribution
over
trees t1 up to tm each of these threes
are is a deterministic
decision tree of depth at most t
and this is um you know describes um
a query algorithms that makes most big
queries and uses randomness
okay so what do we want of this
randomized decision we wanted to compute
the function with
high probability so we wanted to output
for every
single x we wanted to output the value
of f of x
with probability at least two thirds
and this probability is over the random
coins okay
and again we can denote by r of ff the
minimal depth of
randomized decision trees that computes
a given function
all right
all right so so the randomize was sort
of a segue towards the quantum
analog of it the quantum analog is the
one that that i would focus more
uh in today's talk
okay so we talk about quantum algorithms
so
let's start with the basics so in
quantum algorithms
the most basic element is a qubit it's
just
uh you know a superposition over
like a zero and the one we have two
amplitudes
alpha zero and alpha one which are
complex numbers
and the sum of the squares of these
complex of the norms
of these of these numbers equals one
okay so for example a qubit could be
in this position where you have like one
over square root
two the zero instead you're in the zero
state or one over square root two you're
in the one state
okay another another option is
the same but you know the sign of the
amplitude of the one state
is negative so you can also have
negative
coefficients and you can also have
complex coefficients
and more generally you can look at the
system of mq bits
and and then you have an amplitude for
each for each
uh string of this mq-bit so you have two
dm
amplitudes okay
all right so if you're not familiar with
this notation this this notation of this
uh
you know this thing this cat notation
uh it you should just if you are
familiar with you know linear algebra
you should just think of it
as a vector
whose only non-zero empty is the i've
entry
and all the rest are zeros and the if
entry equals one
okay so it's just you know this notation
is just a fancy way of writing
you know
this this is
correspond to a vector of dimension to
the dm
okay so
so what can we do in a quantum algorithm
what can we do to a quantum state we can
measure it
when we measure a qubit or a
sequence of mq bits we would get
the answer i with probability
proportional to
uh half i squared okay and that's
and that makes sense because the sum of
alpha squares equals one so it is a
probability
distribution another thing that we can
do is we can apply unit
transformation or on our quantum states
okay
and your transformation also preserve uh
you know norms so it also preserves
the fact that the sum of i squares
equals one
all right so so what is the analog of
the
the black box model or like the decision
tree model
in quantum algorithms
so let's first uh unfortunately i don't
have
a decision-free picture to to to draw
for you
so i go back to the first picture the
black box model
so how do we how do we extend this black
box model to the quantum setting
so recall that everything that we do
every transformation that we do on our
state should be a unitary
so
the most natural choice is to to
to have the the black box implement the
following uh
transformation if i give it state i
then i want to get as a state as
i want to get back in the state i when i
multiply
the phase or the amplitude by x i so if
x i is
one i'm not doing anything if x is minus
one i'm
flipping the sign of the amplitude
notice that this is this preserves norm
right so
so so if i give it like um
if i give it this vector
then it either produces like
this vector or this
vector so both of them has the same norm
but since i defined this transformation
on the
you know standard basis it naturally
extends to the
to the entire space
and if i take a super position over the
over the question so if i take
superposition over these
eyes with amplitudes alpha eyes i get a
superposition of where the answers
this just follows by by linearity of of
the operation
okay so in some sense you can think of
it as if we're
querying the the black box in
superposition
now this may seem a bit weird because it
seems like we are like
accessing everything in just one query
and but notice that when we measure
we collapse right so so it's the fact
that that we are sort of
have access to the entire stream doesn't
really mean that we can
get the information from the entire
screen you can also think of the
randomized
uh analog so in the randomized analog i
can also query each coordinate with
probability one over n
then after one query i have you know
uh you know i'm i'm still depending on
every every coordinate but i
i'm depending very weakly on every
coordinate
right so so still for for many
for many interesting functions
this it's still hard to compute the
function even
with a few quantum queries to the black
box
okay so for example if you want to
compute the party of the string you
still need to query
um you still need to make n over two
queries
it's linear in n verbs
right so yes
is it uh um
so this for instance does this include a
query where i sort of
try to learn a linear combination of the
excise
or somehow the it's
what you always just learn a particular
bit with some probability
each bit with some probability or um
right so you are getting like if you
give
give the black box a super position you
are getting a super position
over the answers and you could uh apply
them in unitary on that
so so potentially
yes it seems that you could but it's not
any linear
combinations right so you are bounded to
unitary transformations
um
just to say to compare it with the
randomized
model you can also think of the
randomized model as if you are getting a
vector
and then you're getting a vector where
each you know
maybe
maybe in the quantum setting you'll go
from like
this thing to like i x i because i don't
want to have negative signs
but in the quantum setting the the
the vectors that you get can get in the
input and the output will be
probability distributions and the
transformation would be
stochastic matrices and here
you would get vectors of norm one and
the transformation would be
unitary transformations
so you can also you can also view
randomized algorithm in this
in this model i guess
the the input and the output in the
picture you drew
it seems like they're both in the same
basis
at least the notation seems to suggest
that yeah the input and output is in the
same basis and you measure also in the
same basis
but i guess the i in the input and i in
the output are different
so we we can measure in any basis so you
can apply a unit rate transformation
after a query
okay so maybe let me say how does a
general quantum
query algorithm looks like or a quantum
decision tree how it looks like
so you start with some you know the
the simplest quantum state like the all
zero screen
okay and then
you apply d times the following theme so
you first apply some unit rate
transformation in your state
it doesn't depend on the input x and
then you query
x then you apply this uh oracle
unitary okay and then
again you apply some arbitrary uniform
unitary transformation and then you
query
arbitrary unit transformation and query
so on so forth and you do it for d
times in the end you apply another
unitary and you measure
okay so you in the so you get a string
based on the string you decide whether
to accept or reject
okay so that's like the the general
model
right and you can show very nice things
about this so
so bill said i'll show that you know if
you look at like the amplitudes of the
vectors
you look at them as function of the the
input x
then every time you make a query you
increase the degree
by one at most so therefore if you do
d queries the degree of the entries
is it and every time you apply unitary
you are just doing a linear
combination so you don't change the
degree so the degree of the
entries as polynomials in the input x is
d
when you measure you take the squares so
the degree
like the probability that you output
something is like
sum of squares which means that it's a
number of degree
2d and this
gives rise to to to you know connections
between quantum query complexity and
the degree of function as a polynomial
um
yeah okay so
so i guess i mostly wanted to to
introduce this model i'm not sure that
we're gonna
dive too deep in into it uh further
okay so so we discussed like the
deterministic query complexity is the
randomized quantum
you can also talk about the
non-deterministic version in the
nondeterministic version
for example i want to prove to prasad
the value
of majority on my string is one
so then i say you know please look at
coordinates
one and three they are both one so then
i can only reveal
two coordinates and i i'm convincing
prasad that the value of maturity
is one uh
block sensitivity we already saw in in
house talk uh there's the degree which
we also saw
and there's approximate degree i guess i
haven't defined that
so the approximate degree is you want uh
so you have some boolean function
you want some polynomial multi-linear
polynomial
and you look at how it maps like the
boolean inputs
so you want for every x and you want
this polynomial to be
with minimal degree and you want for
every x the value of the polynomial and
the value of the function
to be not too far apart let's say at
most one third apart
and you're looking for like the minimal
d such that there exists some p where
the degree of
p equals d
okay so that's the approximate degree
obviously uh you know if we can compute
the function exactly as a low degree
polynomial then
then we can also approximate it by
loading group pronoun but sometimes
uh this approximate degree is smaller
okay so so these are all uh interesting
complexity measures that were studied
a lot in the past few decades and this
beautiful
line of work by nissan nissan segady and
bill's woman cleve musk and wolf
they showed that all of them are
equivalent
there are like this happy flock that we
saw in
the previous talk uh what what
what do we mean equivalent for each two
complexity measures here
if we look at boolean functions the
complex one complexity measure is
bounded by another to the
sixth power
okay and some in some relations we can
improve the power from six to
two or even one but uh
okay but all of them are polynomially
related and the question of the
sensitivity conjecture another way to
phrase it is whether sensitivity can
join this party
whether sensitivity is also related
to all the rest and right and now we
know that the answer is yes right so now
we know that
uh
based on this amazing result we know
that sensitivity
is polynomially related to all these
complexity measures
all right
so what what next
so i want to introduce an
another a new complexity measure i guess
it was already introduced in the
previous talk
and um it's quite natural and
it's it's it's really
important in the proof of of the
sensitivity conjecture
right so let's say that we have a
boolean function
so i drew here an example of a boolean
function so
right so i have all the like the
three-dimensional hypercube and i marked
some vertices with plus from one and
some vertices with minus one
and this defines a boolean function so
for every for every input and
and define the value of the function by
this drawing
and the the sensitivity graph
corresponding to this function is just
i'm just taking edges in this hypercube
for which the two ends have different
colors
or in other words i'm taking edges such
that if i change
the coordinate corresponding to this
direction i'm changing the value of the
function
so for example this was this the
function on the left is the majority
function on three bits
and the sensitivity a sensitivity graph
is exactly this graph
where this like our graph
okay
so how do i formally define it so you
just connect two
edges if there are neighbors in the
hypercube meaning that they differ from
exactly one coordinate
their harming distance is one and the
value of the f
value of them on them is different okay
and and this 50 graph is exactly the the
graph that
that that how was talking about
uh right so this is the graph that you
get from this gotzman lineal
transformation because when you multiply
the
um the graph of the function with the
the party
and you take the component of the one
point of the minus one is exactly the
graph that you would get i mean it's
simple exercise to see
all right so what would be the
sensitivity
the sensitivity of a function it's just
the you know if we look at this graph
geoff it's just a
maximal degree and now notice that
degree
means something else and degree is a
polynomial so it's a degree in the graph
it's a maximal degree in this graph okay
so for example here the
the sensitivity is two because you can
see there like the maximum degree of
this graph
is two
right so this vertex has two neighbors
and every
i mean there's no vertex with more than
two neighbors
all right so looking closely at the
the proof of juan uh he showed that the
degree
like the the degrees of polynomial of
any function is that mostly since deeply
squared
but you can actually break it down into
these two parts where the degree is at
most
this lambda of f squared
and the second part is that lambda f is
most sensitivity
the second part is really is really
simple the first part is is
is where the ingenuity came
and what is this lambda of f lambda f is
the maximum eigenvalue of the adjacency
matrix of g
right so it's a very natural um
complexity measure of a boolean function
you look at the all
sensitive edges defined by the function
and you look at
you know the spectrum of this
of this jcc matrix or the the maximum
eigenvalue
of this adjacency matrix
all right so
so what i'm going to show you next is
just you know simple observations but
they resolve
long-standing questions
right so
really this lambda is the the new uh
character in this in this story and it
seems to be a very central character
that we haven't
well maybe some people have noticed but
it didn't uh received a lot of attention
uh
right the main result of hwang is that
we have a lower bound on lambda lambda
is
at least square root of the degree right
and based on that we can achieve the
sensitivity conjecture
and right so and
also juan showed us that lambda
is lower bound by square root of
sensitivity
and the reason is as follows so if you
have a vertex with
s neighbors in this graph then the
eigenvalue
of this graph is at least square root s
and and it's a simple exercise it says
the eigenvalue of a star
with s edges is square with this and you
know if we have more edges and
the eigenvalue can only be higher so
so so that's why
right if we have essedges and the
eigenvalue the top eigenvalue
is at least
and i guess a very intriguing question
is whether we can also lower bound
lambda by square root of the block
sensitivity
if this is correct then we would get
that you know we know that this is
upper bounded by the sensitivity then we
would get exactly
uh the the fact that block sensitivity
and sensitivity are
quadratically related right which was
conjecture i guess my nissan zeggetti
in their paper and also we know that
this is the best possible due to this
example by rubinstein okay
what about upper bounds on the on lambda
well we also saw this this upper bound
which is again
simple saying you know if the maximal
degree
is s then the eigenvalue is at most s
okay so this is simple
so we get from this that land is mostly
sensitivity and sensitivity lower bounds
block sensitivity
certificate and decision free complexity
so lambda basically low bounds all these
measures and
our observation is that lambda also
lower bounds this quantum query
complexity
okay so i'm gonna talk about it
in the next slide
but i guess there are two things that
that are still open so
what about lambda versus degree does
lambda lower bounds degree and does
lambda lower bounds approximate degree
so like when we published our
uh manuscript a few months ago we
we call this like conjecture one
conjecture two
and a very exciting recent development
from like
the last few days is that it seems that
we know now how to prove these results
i'm not gonna talk about it because it's
really
uh still a little bit half bay but based
on um
you know discussions with
sravastra we gave a beautiful
approach how to get this conjecture
and and we were able to extend it you
know in this
joint collaboration with scott armstrong
shall have been david
and robin kutari were able to extend it
to this thing
so really lambda lower bounds all the
complexity measure that we
you know i mean okay uh
caveat i mean we still need to verify
all the details but
but assuming that this uh this indeed
works
uh lambda lower bounds all this complex
measure but it's not that small right
it's it's at least square root of the
degree and at least square root of
s so it's it's a very nice uh complexity
measure
um and it will allow us to connect to
get better connection between the other
complexity measures
okay so
so just based on what i told you so far
you can get that for any boolean
function the degree
is at most the quantum query complexity
squared
or rather that the quantum square
complexity is lower bounded by square
root of the degree
okay so the first ingredient is you know
this
this result by like one
and the second ingredient i said it
follows from the result of hombinism
barn sucks and zegedi specifically
so there's a way to there's a lot of
ways to lower bound quantum query
complexity actually
many of them are equivalent so um
unlike what what one said sometimes we
have different names for the same
complexity measure
and we realize it later uh so
so one one method to lower bound quantum
query complexity is called the spectral
adversary method
i'm not going to go into the proof of
this
but basically you need to maximize the
following thing you need to
find the best matrix
uh i guess capital gamma
this is a two to the n by two d and
non-negative matrix
and the only non-negative entries of it
are for
you know x y such that f of x is
different than f of y
okay so this is this is the thing that
you are maximizing over
and you're looking at the spectral norm
of gamma divided by the spectral number
of
a gamma when you only
okay when you only keep the coordinates
for which x and y differ in the
i-coordinate
okay i guess
i guess sorry this is not completely
right
i guess this is the right thing so you
just keep
entries where x and i differ in the f
coordinate
okay and this lower bounds quantum query
complexity i will
not show you the proof but the point is
that you know
it's very simple to see that lambda of f
lower bound this
thing and the reason is just take
this capital gamma to be the adjacency
matrix of g of ff
the eigen the the top eigen value of
this thing is
lambda five and what is this thing
so if i'm just for if i'm picking up
one direction and i'm just keeping the
edges in this direction
so what would be the the top eigen value
of this adjacency matrix
well i have only at most one edge
touching every vertex so the degree is
at most one
for each vertex so the eigen top
eigenvalue is at most one
so therefore the spectral adversary
bound is at least lambda and this also
follows if
by closer inspection it also follows
from the slightly previous work of
combines because we are not really using
the the full power
of this method we are just picking this
capital gamma to be a 0 1 matrix
and this follows from the previous
result of embodies
okay so so
now how do we get the connection between
deterministic decision creating quantum
query complexity where we just combine
it with
known results from the literature so
madriani showed that the deterministic
decision increased at most block
sensitivity times degree
the sun segedly showed that block
sensitivity is most approximate degree
squared
and bill said i'll show that approximate
degree lower bounds quantum query
complexity this is what we discussed
right
that for every quantum query algorithm
you get
polynomials that approximate your
function
so if you combine all these things
together you get that the
deterministic where complex is the most
quality in the quantum query complexity
and i should say okay so let's let's
maybe look at a few examples so
so when f is the or function
we said that the deterministic
complexity is
n but turns out the quantum complexity
is square root n
and this is a well-known result it's
like called growth research
basically it tells you you know you can
find a one in a string
in times square root n if you have a
quantum algorithm
and the lower bound is by bennett
prasad bernstein was irani
so here you can see that there is exists
a quadratic separation between quantum
and deterministic
it was conjecture for many years that
this is the best but actually
then came this walk of ambanis they
showed that there's an
aquatic separation
and shall have been david robin kothari
and scott armstrong also showed the
super quadratic separation between
randomized query complexity and quantum
query complex
so basically this settles the best
separation
between deterministic and quantum
characteristics the best separation is
four
and we have a matching comparable
i just want to mention a few like more
consequences of the first theorem the
one about the
the relation between quantum and in
degree
you can very easily get by that that the
quantum query complexity of or is at
least square root n
and that's just because the degree of or
is n right
we know that theorem one tells us that q
of f is at least
square root of the degree of f
so you get this result by uh bbb
really immediately from this theorem
and you also get like that if you
compose or with ants
so you take like an ore
of ends
you get a lower bound for that as well
and this took
more work i think this was proved for
the first time by ambani's
and more generally if you have any
formula de morgan formula
that only reads every variable once
then you you get a quantum lower bound
of square root
n and remarkably there's also a quantum
upper bound of square root 10
so we know the quantum query complexity
of every demorgan formula that reads
every input one it's square root
n and
i believe that these are all known
results but you get a very simple
very simple proof for all these results
because the degree of this of these
functions is at least n is exactly
awesome
okay another another thing that we get
is a sort of a
resolution of the quantum analog of the
evasiveness conjecture
um this is a long-standing conjecture by
andrea carp rosenberg the conjecture
that if
the function is a is a graph property
i mean you think of the input as as
indicating for each edge whether
it's in the graph or not and the graph
property is you know something like you
know is a graph
ball is a graph connected um
is it does the graph contain a cycle of
length
or i know things like that so these are
things that do not depend on the naming
of the vertices
so that's a graph property and the
conjecture is that
if you want to compute that for any
graph property you have to query all the
edges
okay and currently the best
known lower bound is that there that you
need to query at least the constant
times
all the edges okay
there's also an analog for the
randomized setting
saying that if you want to answer with
high probability you need to query it is
the constant times
the number of like a constant fraction
of the number of edges
and the best and non-lower bounds is uh
polynomially related so it's like n to
the four thirds instead of n squared
and for the quantum analog what we we
can show
very easily by qrm1 is that
uh you need at least n queries
and the reason is that uh so based on
this result
you can also show like if you adapt it
you can show that the degree is at least
n squared this is a result and
i forget but it's it's ron rivers and
another guy that i'm forgetting the name
and you know since the degree is
quadratic the quantum query complexity
is at least
linear and this is also tight because
you know the property the graph property
could be are you containing an
edge and then you can do growth research
do are you the empty graph so
so so it's very simple consequences of
of uh one result that proved
long-standing conjecture so
now i wanted to show you this uh table
so we talked about all this complexity
measure
there's a nice table and i guess we
bought it from
previous paper by arson ben david and
kotari and now we
updated it so you can see for every two
complexity measures let's let's look i
don't know here
maybe so
you can see this entry it says like two
numbers two and three
it says you should interpret it as as
follows
we know that for every boolean function
the deterministic
query complexity that most the
randomized raised to the power free
and we know that this cannot improve
beyond two we know that there exists
some functions
such as the deterministic
is at least the randomized square
okay
so okay i'm not going to go into all the
details here
i just want to say that you know we
improved a lot of entries like
just one result improved all the entries
marketing
in green in this in this table
and based on this new um
you work with ben david kotari in arms
only we get all the red ones
and i guess if we uh based on on this
new result
that i was promoting that that we were
like in the
middle of writing we would get a bunch
of new ones as well
uh i want to point out that if you are
interested in
in seeing this
table there's a very nice website that
that a student in berkeley
uh wrote uh the name of student is alex
hue and you can see the
oops sorry you can see the the link here
and i will post the slides later so you
can look at the link
and you can also insert new relations
that you have and it will sort of
uh find all the the the implication of
it because
for a lot of these entries are sort of
you combine a lot of
known results okay so so this
table is smart it's sort of you give
them like
five results and it gets you all this
big table
right so let me finish by mentioning
that you know this table is still not
complete and there's a few
uh nice open problems that i want to
highlight
more than others like what is the best
separation between randomized and
quantum query complexity we figure out
between deterministic and quantum but
not between randomizing
quantum and here we know that the
exponent should
should be between uh two and two thirds
and
four and it seems likely that it's two
and two thirds could be improved to free
and this is another uh work based on
a work of ambanis and aaronson
but we still don't know what the right
answer maybe three is the right answer
uh we discuss this block sensitivity
versus sensitivity
we know that the exponent should be
between two and four
deterministic decision tree and block
sensitivity
it should be between two and three uh
actually
this was like highlighted for many years
as like the way to get the best
uh relation between deterministic and
quantum query complexity if you can show
that this is the right answer you would
also get this quartic
uh relation and and finally so if you
look at this
this graph so this is like a graph of
all this complexity measure if you're
higher it means that
the complexity measure is bigger than
the previous one so deterministic query
compass is always bigger than randomized
which is always bigger than quantum
which is bigger than approximate degree
so really lambda sits at the bottom and
deterministic
this increase sits on on the top so we
really want to get like the best
like if we can get like the best
relation between
these two
uh maybe it's a fourth power then we
would get that all of them
are related by a fourth power so here
this is between four and six
and if you're interested in this topic i
i really recommend this
survey by burman and the wolf uh
it's it's really a wonderful
introduction to this area and also
to the quantum uh model which um
i was always afraid of going into but
this survey is so nice
that it's it's really inviting to this
field
and there's like uh so this is like from
20 years ago but but still
very relevant but a more recent uh work
by arson ben david kontari
talking about separations using cheat
sheet is maybe
um another reference that is worthwhile
uh looking into if you're
interested in these topics um
yeah i guess that's it thanks
all right yeah i guess uh it's been a
long day so
any questions
so um i had a question the
sa bound is that uh essay spectral
adversaries are equal to the quantum
query complexity
right so no you you could uh
there is a uh
a more refined uh lower bounds in this
paper of barnum sucks and zegetty uh
that exactly equals so so basically they
capture quantum work complexity by a
semi-definite
programming and this is like the dual
um but this is like a relaxation of it
it's easier to handle but it's not
tight okay yeah so
there's a question on the um
stream uh you all uh asks are there any
applications between
complexity measures of relations between
complexity measures
yeah i mean we usually want to know
right what are the what is the query
complexity what is the quantum query
completely randomized domestic so
usually
like sometimes due to these connections
we get
lower bounds and upper bounds on precise
measures for example we want to
understand if grover search could be
improved
and no it cannot because
we have star bound that the approximate
degree is at least
square root 10 and therefore the quantum
query complexity is
d squared and so so i guess maybe
in in nailing down the the query
complexities
these are all like lower and upper upper
bound methods
there's another question
oh there's another question by subhan uh
is there
any connection with these new bounds for
quantum
communication complexity of total
functions
um
right so usually when you have a
separation i mean we talked about
relations more
but usually when you have a separation
you can lift it
to the communication complexity and
it could be that in the communication
box you have bigger separation between
these analogs
so i don't i don't see immediately what
you would get by
these relations but but i'm not an
expert on
these lifting results
results awesome yeah
okay
all right thanks for sticking
for two hours thanks for the talk